CAPACITY CROWD.
NOW HE IS HEARING IT FROM THE
CROWD.
>> Kenny: RANDLE FINALLY
CONNECTS AFTER MISSING THREE IN
A ROW.
SEVEN-POINT GAME.
OUBRE FROM THREE.
REBOUNDED BY RANDLE.
>> Walt: SEE, MOST TEAMS WOULD
NOT SHOOT THE BALL THERE.
>> Kenny: RIGHT.
WHY NOT TAKE TIME OFF THE CLOCK?
>> Walt: YEAH.
IT SHOWS YOU HOW TEAMS SQUANDER
LEADS.
OUBRE PREVIOUSLY WAS A CULPRIT
WITH ILL-ADVISED TURNOVER.
NOW SHOOTING THIS BALL FROM THE
CORNER.
YOU SEE MICHAEL SAYING THE SAME
THING, WHY WOULD YOU SHOOT THAT
BALL?
RUN THE CLOCK OUT!
>> Kenny: 29.4 REMAINING.
STAY TUNED AFTER THE GAME FOR
THE POSTGAME SHOW.
BILL, ALAN, WALLY FOR THAT.
>> Walt: DEJA VU FOR THOSE GUYS.
WE SAW A SIMILAR SCENARIO WE SAW
IN NEW YORK WHERE THE